from Canada you're living here now so
this is dual citizen so this is your
first chance to vote in an election in
the UK are you going to vote we know a
lot of young people armed are you going
to know of course yeah imagine if I
wasn't yeah of course I'm so excited
do you think the politicians are
speaking a language that you and that
young people understand that the message
is getting through no that's why I think
today is amazing this is really
important to kind of modernize the way
the government interacts with young
people and it seems like when I watch TV
all I hear is about cutting public
spending and you know lowering the
deficit but yeah so it's important to
grill people today guys yeah yeah I've
got some real me at Webb's have got some
great questions from from the guys in
the audience Jamal are you going to vote
we know a lot of young people aren't I'm
registered to vote I feel like it's
asked a lot of people aren't register
software like if there's no politicians
that I'm making policies towards me then
I'll spoil my ballot I think a lot of
people don't realize that and can
actually do that and then your vote my
friend and I think people get into their
head I need to vote for any of the
leaders I'm in power but it don't
actually realize you can mark and then
not for it as well spoiling your ballot
would achieve if when you go in there I
think if the the message was send our
imagine if you had a certain amount that
voted that didn't vote for n s Prime
Minister then actually voted for the
Prime Minister that was so that we are
engaged and we need to make policies for
us that's what I think the message would
be
what about Russell Brand he's famous he
told people not to vote but then it's
not worth it I mean he has a point
doesn't it a lot of people agree with
him yeah it's so easy to feel to feel
overwhelmed and like things are terrible
but I think not voting is not the answer
I think he's very handsome though he's
very persuasive and handsome well that's
got a little that's going to sway a lot
of people I hope not like stay cool
don't listen to him just cuz you know in
the old days it seemed like there are
tons of public figures talking about
politics right like the Beatles and
stuff but now everybody's just trying to
sell you a fragrance so at least he's
talking about it